the westerlands are all bounded by three
natural defenses
mountain sea and forest
necessary barriers when the land is as
rich as ours
from our minds come the gold and silver
that fuel the rest of westeros
from lannisport our largest city come
the most skillful gold and silversmiths
in the land
yet geography alone is not strength
the westerlands would have been sacked
and pillaged for thousands of years if
it hadn't been for the men who ruled it
my family
house lannister
according to legend we trace our descent
to land the clever
the trickster of the dawn age who
swindled the casterlies out of casterly
rock their ancient castle
a childish story but not without merit
one
a mind can and should be a weapon in a
man's arsenal
two
land must have been clever enough not to
rely solely on his wits
after all where today is house casterly
three
by keeping the casterly name on the
castle
lan reminded the world of the price of
getting in his way
the reigns ignored all these lessons
not content with being the second
richest family they sought to challenge
the first
mine
my father had put up with their insults
and disrespect
when i came of age
i led our army to teach them what they
should have known
some people say i was too harsh that
eradicating every member of their family
was not necessary
but now
there are no bannermen as loyal to their
lord as the westerlands to us
if any lord bridles at our authority i
have only to send a singer with a harp
and he falls back into line
fools look at the westerlands and see
gold
fools see our wealth and call it
strength
gold is just another rock
the westerlands are strong because of
house lannister
from strong leadership comes unity
from unity
comes power my ancestor king lauren of
house lannister was head of the
wealthiest family in the seven kingdoms
when king lauren joined his forces to
mourn of house gardener king of the
reach
they had the mightiest army in history
a so-called iron fist
to break the would-be conqueror but
while an iron fist can smash a man's
face in battle you'd look silly hunting
birds or beasts with it
an aegon had a creature that was both
the kings had never even seen a dragon
let alone fought one
they had fought each other for thousands
of years and victory always went to the
larger army
surely a force five times that of
aegon's could manage one dragon
but aegon arrived with three
still the lannisters and gardeners hoped
for victory the battlefield they chose
was a wide plane with firm ground and
clear skies perfect for archers and
mounted cavalry
but neither of the kings spared a
thought for why the ground was firm
there had been no rain for a fortnight
which meant all the wheat and grass on
it were bone dry
perfect for dragons
at first the kings looked like they
would emerge victorious
when the horn blew for battle their
armies swept around aegon's flanks and
there are iron fists of mounted knight
smashed through his center before the
dragons could even enter the fray
but then hagen and his sisters took
flight and unleashed their dragons not
on the soldiers but on the dry fields
all around them
the iron fists
unclenched and became a hand
outstretched for mercy
as aegon promised he had none
more than four thousand men died in the
fires another thousand escaping them
tens of thousands returned home as
monsters burned and scarred beyond
recognition
house gardener never returned at all the
field of fire as the singers call it
claimed the last of the garden line and
house tyrell rose in their stead as
lords of the reach and wardens of the
south
as for my illustrious ancestor when king
lawrence saw the battle was lost he rode
through a wall of flame and smoke to
safety
or at least to a heroic capture day
later where he laid his sword before
aegon and knelt
again true to his words spared him and
confirmed house lannister as lords of
casterly rock and wardens of the west
why wouldn't he the lannister always
pays his debts
and now we owed our lives to the crown
that was worth centuries of subservience
at least
besides aegon had a fetish for
collecting swords not heads
he added lawrence to the pile his men
had retrieved from the field of fire and
sent them back to the aegon fort
years later the realm had no sharper
minds than lord tywin lannister hand to
king aerys targaryen
or as history remembers him the mad king
he saw assassins and plots in every
shadow heard whispers in silence and
burned men alive
but his greatest madness by far was
driving away lord tywin
the mad king then cycled through every
mistake of his ancestors
soldiers toading lords and at the end
even an alchemist perhaps to save the
crown's growing expenses on wildfire
unfortunately it didn't save his crown
or his dynasty
as aries targaryen's behavior grew more
and more erratic the task of ruling the
seven kingdoms fell to me time in
lannister
i had served aries for nearly 20 years
and as a result the realm had prospered
the royal coffers were full the land was
at peace
but aries grew increasingly hostile
jealous of the success many credited to
me
my power and influence unnerved him
the captain of my personal guard sir
ellen payne was once overheard making
off-hand comments regarding who was the
true ruler of westeros
when the king was given this information
he had elim payne's tongue ripped out
with hot pincers
it was my desire to unite the houses of
lannister and targaryen through marriage
my daughter cersei would marry aries
eldest son prince rhaegar
union made perfect sense for all parties
however
aries senses had begun to leave him
quite some time earlier
instead of uniting the royal family with
its most loyal and powerful ally
ares chose instead to insult my family
indicating that such a match was beneath
rhaegar
instead he chose elia martell of dawn to
be rhaegar's wife
as if to rub salt in my wounds ares
appointed jaime my son to the king's
guard
the king's guard may be an honor for
lesser families than ours
but it is a lifetime appointment that
forces him to renounce all family
holdings
this creates a difficulty in naming an
heir to casterly rock
but ares knew all that
i had grown tired of the king's constant
provocation
thus i resigned my post as aerys hand
and returned to casterly rock
with my considerable forces
when robert baratheon rebelled against
the throne
ares grew fearful that i would join with
robert's forces and rise against him
he thought himself clever and kept jaime
very close as if warning me
he sunk deeper and deeper into delusion
paranoia and violence
rhaegar targaryen lay dead on the banks
of the trident
his royal army shattered and in retreat
the days of the dragon kings were
clearly numbered
until that moment it would have been
foolish to commit casterly rock to
either the crown or the rebellion
what would our family have to gain in
supporting a raving madman
or in entering a crusade to put robert
baratheon on the iron throne
but chaos benefits no one
it was time for house lannister to do
what it could to ensure a return of
peace and prosperity to the land
i tywin lannister brought ten thousand
lannister troops to the gates of king's
landing in order to bring the bloodshed
to a quick and decisive conclusion
king aerys had been sending ravens for
months begging for my support to end the
uprising
in a way
his pleas had been answered
as i had suspected ares opened the city
gates and welcomed my men
our plan was clear crush ares remaining
bannermen and remove the remnants of the
royal family as quickly and efficiently
as possible
any alternative meant years of further
war and a fragmented seven kingdoms
our means were bloody
but the results speak for themselves
as for aries it is true he met his fate
at the hands of my son
aerys had kept jamie close during the
rebellion thinking himself clever in
keeping my son as a hostage should i
decide to pledge support to the rebel
cause
this proved to be his greatest mistake
for when the time came
jaime did his duty as a lannister
and drove his sword into the mad king's
back
my father's knights burst into the hall
in time to see the last of it so there
was no way for me to vanish and let some
brackets steal the glory or blame
i knew at once when i saw the way they
looked at me
it would be blame
lannister i know i'd been one of paris
as kingsguard i commanded them to
announce that the mad king was dead and
to spare all those who yielded
they asked me if they should proclaim a
new king as well
i knew what they meant would it be my
father or robert baratheon or maybe the
child viserys who'd fled to dragonstone
a targaryen boy king with my father's
hand to rule in truth
i thought of how ned stark and robert
baratheon would howl at this end to
their great heroic war and i was tempted
then i glanced down again at ares his
life's blood oozing from the wound and
pooling on the floor around him
proclaim who you bloody well like i said
i climbed the steps to the iron throne
and sat on it with my sword across my
knees
waiting to see who would come to claim
the kingdom
you